and there you have one in portugal a
delicious
personalized jr omelette how sad is that
[ __ ] idiot
now you know i love eggs and so i'm
gonna do a little bit of scrambled uh
here in portugal but with a twist
because it's not a scrambled egg it's
gonna be an amazing omelette made with
teresa asparagus a little bit of pepper
shallots but i'm not talking about any
kind of trees though i'm talking about
the porco preto this is the black pig
chorizo uh incredible the flavor is
unique we're gonna keep it a little bit
more sort of portuguese as opposed to
the spanish omelet but uh it's gonna
taste delicious first things first i'm
gonna take this chorizo look at the fat
in there the color honestly so beautiful
now you can either grate this or just
dice it up i'm going to dice it up into
little cubes
not too small otherwise it'll sort of
disintegrate now i want the oils
separating from there
but i want the flavor okay
and you wait to see the way
this literally
colors the eggs and colors the asparagus
is so beautiful
get a little bit of
onion in there
some shallots nothing fancy here okay
it's a rustic portuguese style
omelette
slice them all together
and from there get the asparagus tips
these are young asparagus okay all i'm
gonna do is cut them into about an inch
long little spares
and literally
now look at the color starting to build
up and it's all raw still
a little bit of the padron peppers local
peppers give a touch of heat in there as
well seeds kept in nothing wrong with
that
a little bit
of local mushrooms as well into a bowl
that goes
okay
a bit of salt
a little bit of pepper
and just
a little teaspoon
of olive oil okay to get that going
and a little touch of butter that'll
really help caramelize and brown
the ingredients now
over to the pan mix that up
pan is super hot
really important now to get the
ingredients ready first before we start
cooking those eggs ingredients in
beautiful
now
the chorizo is working its magic
it's starting to sort of break down the
smells are amazing
the butter it's gonna give those
vegetables a really nice sort of nut
brown flavor
getting all the water out the vegetables
that way the texture on the omelet is
delicious
and look
flatten everything out if we flatten
everything out in the pan it cooks so
much quicker now you can see the color
of those vegetables it's been stained
with that amazing rich garlicky oil
coming out of the chorizo
beautiful now let's not get them too
dark okay
just color them enough
in a way that we're going to add them
back in
to the omelette
and so that's really important to sort
of keep it
nice
and light back off
okay that goes in
look at that flavor in there oh my god
now
in there
i'm gonna add some parsley get it all
done now so
inside that omelette that flavor is
locked in there okay
and the stick behind any great omelettes
to make sure it's just a little bit
runny in the middle
eggs continue cooking as you know
now look
parsley in
okay
and that's the filling
for my omelette now look at that
that's beautiful clean out the pan
a little touch
of olive oil in just a splash
a little touch of butter
and now we're going to start the omelet
okay that goes on the stove not too hot
on and then we start the eggs
very carefully crack the eggs
in
i like
four or five eggs for the omelet because
this is the kind of omelet that you can
literally cut in half
they can serve for two or even three
guests no seasoning omelette yet really
important five eggs in
a light whisk
just a light whisk and all i'm gonna do
is put some pepper in there open up the
top of the pepper mill so it opens up
and gets really nice and peppery
in
like whisk no salt really important okay
from there a little touch of butter in
there okay and then literally a little
drizzle of olive oil now this is where
it's going to be super quick okay
because this thing moves very fast eggs
salt
and ingredients let's go
take your pan
getting nice and hot
eggs
in this is where you start to work that
omelette okay
work it round
you can see it's just starting to fry
take it off the heat a little bit
once it starts cooking all the way
through you can see okay now
you start to make it nice and flat
really important don't do that too early
okay
and then from there
super hot
get your mixture
okay and start filling in the center i
always say the center so we can fold it
nicely
okay
hold it like a little pillow
the smells are incredible
okay
and then look
from there
put that back on the heat for 30 seconds
you season the inside of that now you
can't seize an omelette after it's
folded season inside
back off
this is where the magic happens right
here follow me
right tilt the pan up
over over
i've kept it nice and thick so it's a
lot more difficult
okay once you get to that stage tilt the
pan up
let the pan do the work
get your plate
and fold
now
one more little thing watch
just
and there you go
as if you need to know whose omelette it
is it's mine because you've got my
initials on there come on a little bit
of fun
but a delicious incredible portuguese
omelets
now if you like that
as much as i do then please leave a
comment and if you did miss the
uncharted then follow the link below to
see it all over again